I'm out on the great ocean road and I've
just spotted my first koala in the wild
since moving to Australia seven years
ago he's pretty amazing it looks like
he's just broken up and he's a little
bit groggy as you can see koalas don't
really do that much
oh no oh no that's cool that's a bad
idea
I bet that he likes being chased like
that
[Music]
as you can see he doesn't really do very
much in fact koalas can sleep about 20
hours a day and that's because the
eucalyptus leaves they eat are not
particularly nutritious and they're very
difficult to digest
in fact they have some bacteria in their
gut that helps them digest those leaves
and when a baby koala is born it doesn't
actually have that bacteria and it's got
so the first thing it has to do is eat
its mummy foods
so that's its first meal not really the
best way to enter life but there you go
that's the life of a koala and most the
rest of life is sleeping and eating
those crappy leaves doesn't sound like a
lot of fun I don't think I would like it
when you think about the awesome
specimens that evolution has produced
it's a wonder these guys are still alive
[Music]